also ich muss sagen darauf freue ich
mich eigentlich am meisten ich weiß
nicht seht ihr das hier das sieht auch
wirklich gar nicht verkehrt aus wenn man
das jetzt hier mal so dann leuchtet
etwas geht ab und herzlich willkommen zu
einem neuen video
ich hoffe natürlich geht es gut
der tisch wackelt ich muss sagen für
mich geht es jetzt also wir haben heute
samstag ich will noch ein video vor
produzieren weil ich finds nach köln und
ich bin auch bis dienstagabend köln weil
ich noch einen dreh habt in köln und ich
hatte auf meiner liste eigentlich noch
car crashes von milch also das habe ich
mal bestellt und ja deswegen geht es
darum heute ich weiß dass eine sache
nicht angekommen ist ich glaube hängt
beim zoll oder so das war so eine
rückenmassage konnte halt ins auto legen
ich kann euch hier gerne ein foto ein
bin und dann halte ich massieren lassen
ist natürlich super schade aber leider
ist nicht angekommen wenn sie noch kommt
dann stelle ich mich irgendwann mal vor
auf jeden fall schlafen mal rein ich
wünsche euch dass gefragt und wir fangen
hier mit anfassen
ich weiß auch gar nicht genau
[Musik]
leute das hier ist das erste produkt wir
haben hier eine auto lenkrad abdeckung
und zwar wenn man irgendwie auto fährt
und so am lenkrad rutscht weil das zu
rutschig ist bietet sich das natürlich
an
ich war das bei meinem auto jetzt
einfach mal aufs lenkrad und mal gucken
wie das aussieht wird bestimmt verrückt
hast du eigentlich zu haben ein bisschen
blau werden wir uns da sind auch schon
wieder im auto mit folgendem produkt
hinten liegt moment ich habe das schon
getestet gerade weil ich dachte so etwas
passt doch niemals darüber und ich muss
ganz ehrlich sagen jetzt bei meinem
lenkrad bietet sich das nicht an weil
das lenkrad ist einfach sehr sehr sexy
sohn einfach auch nissan zu fassen aber
wenn das lenkrad schon ein bisschen
abgenutzt oder so da einfach sehr
rutschig ist dann ist das gar nicht mal
schlecht wir ziehen das einfach hier mal
darüber muss man ein bisschen kraft
haben muss halt auch sagen wenn das
lenkrad noch größer ist als mainz und es
gibt auf jeden fall lenkräder die größer
sind als dieses hier so sieht das halt
jetzt aus eigentlich passt das auch die
farben passen das sieht schon gar nicht
mal so schlecht aus aber wenn ihr ein
größeres lenkrad passt das halt nicht
mehr
trotzdem von mir gibt es hierfür für
dieses produkt auf jeden fall
lange weiter mit dem nächsten produkt
also ich weiß nicht was ist heiß also
ich brauche das nicht aber ich habe
natürlich auch an die leute gedacht die
sich das erste auto hole mit 18 und
eventuell noch nicht das geld haben für
ein auto mit klimaanlage hatte ich
damals auch nicht mit 18 jahren
aber ich hatte halt auch kein eigenes
auto wir haben hier eine klimaanlage
glaube ich bloß jr auto parkt kann wie
ich will aber kalte luft natürlich solar
powered ventilationssystem okay ich bin
jetzt karten bistum überfragt als wenn
das einfach nur mit solarenergie
funktioniert so sieht es aus und hier
haben wir ein kabel das wird ja schon
auseinander hier alter was das denn man
solar sunpower auto lüfter luft
entlüftung kühler passt auch immer du
kannst es anscheinend so irgendwie dahin
klemmen und dann wie soll das denn gehen
junge es bleibt das hält ja nicht mal
denken was ist das denn für ein drittes
produkt junge ist das von mir kriegt es
auf jeden fall ein stern wolfs dingen
aber wir probieren es natürlich trotzdem
aus
das hat mich gerade bisschen aggressiv
gemacht das muss irgendwie an die
scheibe und dann kann das ich muss das
ausprobieren möchte keine ahnung wie wir
sind gerade auf dem weg nach mainz
testen wir gerade die neue klimaanlage
herunter gefallen also das ist ein
absolutes funktioniert nämlich das
pendel wieder abgegangen heute ich muss
wirklich sagen dieses ding hier also das
ist wirklich der größte vorziehen skript
funktioniert absolut dich auch gestern
hat die sonne geschienen als ich zurück
gefahren bin da tut sich gar nichts und
wenn er nur ganz ganz wenig also das ist
ich weiß auch nicht was sie sich dabei
gedacht haben kompletter müll war auch
nicht teuer ich weiß aber dann kann man
es auch gleich sein lassen das zu
produzieren weil ich ja das ist also
seiten so einen schrott produkt gesehen
kann man gut mit reifen vielleicht oper
la punt jetzt das auch schon kaputt
gegangen scheiß dem auto fan ja genau
was ist denn da drin eigentlich eine
schraube noch nicht viel
heute kommen wir zum nächsten produkt
und zwar fand ich das eigentlich ganz
cool da gibt es ganz viele verschiedene
von wir haben ja alfa romeo toyota fiat
suzuki und natürlich auch bmw das kann
man so schön in die getränke
ablagerungen legen
und da habe ich mir gedacht das
bestellte ich mir markt wobei mir jetzt
auffällt das ist natürlich nicht das
originale logo aber an sich muss ich
sagen das ist echt nice weil ich hatte
schon sehr oft das problem dass halt
mein getränk irgendwie oder von mcdonald
scho behälter übergelaufen ist und dann
hast du da halt dann die klebe reiterin
deswegen bin ich ziemlich froh dass
jetzt zu haben ich hoffe das passt auch
gut drei hektar aus ich muss sagen das
nächste produkt ist eigentlich also wo
ist es denn jetzt haben was doch ihr
habt ja eben schon meine begeisterung
gesehen das ist eigentlich perfekt macht
hier ist jetzt müll drin das ist ja
eigentlich ist ja kein müll drin und
zwar wurden hier direkt
freundlicherweise zwei von diesen
dingern geliefert ivana nicht teuer
abgesehen ich habe jetzt hier drei
getränkebecher 123 bei einem letzten
auto da gab es unten sonne ja da war
sowas bei das konzert rausziehen und
dann schön sauber machen das hat der
hier jetzt nicht deswegen bietet sich
das echt an wir können das hier einfach
rein legen und das andere kommt dann
jetzt mal nach hinten eigentlich brauche
ich noch eins aber zwei ist ja schon mal
besser als nix und das sieht jetzt so
aus wie also sieht aus als wäre das von
anfang an dabei gewesen das gab es ja
auch mit allen anderen möglichen
automarken
das logo ist ein bisschen knapp gehalten
hat okay heute weiter geht's jetzt bin
ich wirklich mal gespannt
ich hoffe das ist dass ich glaube schon
ja okay auch jemand foto dazu weil man
muss sagen hatte ich immer wenn man die
türen aufgemacht hat sondern fährt also
es wird außenspiegel raus auf die straße
projiziert dann hast du so einleuchtend
auf dem boden sagt ultra stick aus bei
dem bmw gibt es das leider nicht aber
gar kein problem das kann man nachrüsten
lassen beim hersteller natürlich für
1500 2000 euro oder ihr bestellt ist
einfach auf mich für was habe ich
bezahlt
und hier müssen dann jetzt batterien und
dann ist hier so ein kleber bei leute
das müssen wir ausprobieren
leute was geht nächster spot wir sind
jetzt hier externer tiefgarage weil ich
brauch dunkelheit und hier ist es jetzt
schön dunkel warte jetzt noch nicht so
gut dass es dunkel ist wir jetzt nicht
über zu diesem boden licht ich weiß nich
melden wir uns genau nennt ich hatte den
begriff also ich muss sagen darauf freue
ich mich eigentlich am meisten ich weiß
nicht seht ihr das das sieht auch
wirklich gar nicht verkehrt aus wenn man
das jetzt hier mal so dann leuchtet
schön knackig farbiges bmw licht und das
kann man jetzt auch ganz einfach an der
außentür montieren da war so ein
klebestreifen dabei der jetzt
hoffentlich nicht mein lang komplett
zerfleischt hast machst du rein formal
okay leute ihr könnt mich glaube ich
gerade nicht so gut sehen ich habe das
gericht jetzt angebracht jetzt passt mal
auf wir hoffen jetzt mal das auto
warte mal ich leg die kamera ich stelle
hier vorne kurz auf den boden
also an sich das wirklich leistet jetzt
auch noch mal von dieser sicht auto tür
geht auf
und ja ich weiss nicht man muss auch
sagen das ding hat irgendwie so ein
sensor dass das automatisch angeht wenn
man die tür bewegung ist das geradezu
vor also schlecht ist es nicht es sieht
schon krass aus glaube ich sofort aus
wenn man das sieht ihr könnt ja gern mal
eure meinung in die kommentare schreiben
ja das war es dann auch leider schon ich
weiß das war ein bisschen kürzer heute
tut mir ein bisschen leid aber es kommen
auf jeden fall ist montags bis freitags
immer videos viele produkte ausgepackt
viele sachen werden getestet immer alles
direkt schön und knackig auf den punkt
nicht zu lange abonniert super g in den
kanal wir sehen uns dann morgen 19 uhr
gibt es das video das was mir haut rein
schenkt die letzten videos ab